but we went to the Dustin Poirier to
fighter and he's a Louisiana fighter and
he fights other men for title belts and
acclaim and championships and he took me
to just a place where they were doing
some practicing they were sparring and
rolling and man I didn't realize what a
what an experience it was at this place
you know these people paired off and
next thing you know they're they're I
mean they're they're kind of they're
going against each each other but each
interaction is really just more of an
experience to help the weaker one learn
and when I say weaker I mean whoever is
weaker in whatever skill set they are
practicing so it's kind of like you know
watching this was Brazil Brazilians is
you just use it to and I thought that
was a dog when I first heard about it I
was like damn you got a Brazilian
Jujitsu how old is it but it's a sport
and it's an athletic sport and it's
really it's one of the most Cavalier
type of sports because it's two men it's
two you know and some of them are
beautiful men and some of them looked
like they could be modeling you know
we're doing or definitely they got some
real legs on them some of them and I
mean damn the back strap on a couple of
these boys and make me [ __ ] fire up
the grill you know make daddy wanna eat
yeah a ma but anyway what I'm saying is
that they get out there and they get in
these different predicaments and one of
them will be in front of the other one
or one of them sometimes they'll be on
the other ones kind of rear like what
I'm trying to hide uh you know like one
of them trying to protect a little
raspberry and the other one trying to
get that berry and so it's very
intricate they try to be sneaky and
sneak around each other and it's almost
like they're trying to it's like they're
it's almost like their loop it's like
they're mean they're
looking for something but neither one of
them has it but they're kind of
pretending like the other one has it I
can't explain it really but it's like
chess they they kind of use their bodies
to you know doing leverage and it's it's
like somebody it's like two dudes
massaging each other really extremely
fast and aggressively and in unique
places and sometimes one of them can't
handle the massage and he'll tap out
it's um but it really blew my mind on on
just the skill sets that went into this
this Brazilian Jujitsu and I just wrote
it down right here it just blew my mind
just watching them you know there's just
so much I could see how every time you
do it you're learning at a core mental
level it just it seemed very tribal to
me it was awesome it was a really really
unique experience and it was inspiring
and I'm glad I went in and and and saw
people do this because I've never seen
this before imagine seeing something now
imagine not seeing it that was me I'd
never seen this type of activity so to
see people you know when young men and
their I mean everybody was just sweating
and just fired up but it was never
aggression against each other it was
almost a it was just a group learning
that was going on
Afeni really really it was it was
awesome man it was awesome it was a good
experience
evening good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one
ah